[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
and uh you're listening to barrel of a
gun
uh one of the songs on the sunspin album
that's available everywhere itunes
spotify
amazon you go to sunspin.com and pick up
cool sweet merch
bear love a gun it's one of my favorites
on the album
hi guys how are you ryan that was a gun
noise
i was it scared me i was frightened uh
we did something fun
the other night we did we went to uh i
rented a theater out
uh you could do that so it's safe and
everybody wore masks and there was 20 of
well it was probably like 15 of us and
we saw back to the future at a
private theater i hadn't been to a
theater i i didn't realize how much i
loved the theater
or the theater the theater until i was
there with an e at the end
it was really fun and back to the future
was so good and i hadn't seen it in a
while
i think the last time i saw back to the
future was also in the theater for like
the
25th anniversary which had been 10 years
ago wow
and you loved it just as much yeah it's
it's one that you have to see in a
theater you have to see it in the
theater it was really a good time
i will say that so you know there's some
the light at the end of the tunnel it's
uh we had a good time it was nice to be
with friends
um i told everybody to get there 15
minutes early and i was late because uh
well i was at the wrong theater so there
you have it
um thanks for coming to the stage guys
it means the world to me uh every last
saturday of the month i do a stage it
with rob
our band sunspin and we play music we
have prizes and zooms and all that stuff
and it was just a really good time great
turnout and i just want to say thank you
everybody for the support and love and
uh hope you had fun
i hope you had a good time um if you uh
the most important thing here is uh
subscribing to the podcast if you're
here for kefir sutherland and jason
patrick well thank you for being here
i appreciate it but if you want to help
this little podcast that could tell them
where they can go ryan
uh you could go to hell you can go
[ __ ] yourself go to [ __ ] hospital yeah
uh no
then uh no you can go to yeah uh apple
podcast spotify
uh you can go follow on the twitter
inside of you
pod pod uh and uh instagram facebook
inside of your podcast
that's correct and you they can
subscribe on youtube
go to youtube youtube youtube.com inside
of you with michael rosenbaum the whole
thing
if you want to watch it so uh that would
be great so yeah head over to youtube
subscribe or listen to apple on your way
to work uh
the podcasts aren't that long they're
about an hour so
you know your way to work maybe you're
way back but you're not gonna listen to
three hour podcast which takes you three
days to listen to this is easy and fun
and you're gonna learn a lot i hope
uh but i really appreciate you guys
listening big shout out to all my
patrons
um also if you want any insider you
merch lex luthor stuff
smallville lunch boxes inside of you
hats uh new trucker hats are here
black trucker hats are just awesome
tumblers
bunch of stuff go to the inside of you
online store
and how about disco disco discount code
let's do uh ryan's d
ryan no ryan's discount what do you
think i was gonna say
pervert ryan's discount
15 for 15 off everything in the side of
your online store get that because it's
only going to be for a couple days
ryan's is there an apostrophe no no
apostrophe mm-hmm
ryan's brian's discount 15.
can you remember that ryan's discount
15. you know it's been uh
it's been a couple weeks now since since
my pup passed irv
and uh people were like how you doing
and always asking me it was
it's just a beautiful thing how folks
have been just sending me all these
messages and
it's you know some days are tough when i
really start to think about it when i'm
not busy it's it's always about
distracting yourself
but also you have to feel it you have to
feel the love and feel how much you
loved him and you know i definitely get
those moments and i
have his collar that i put a little
shrine
for irv uh in the living room and um and
so it's been cool
people have been uh awesome so i thank
you guys
immensely for that um cool stuff going
on man you know me and welling
um i'm not gonna say anything but we're
working on a project together hopefully
that will happen
but uh i'm sure a lot of folks like to
see us together again
doing something yeah man just been i've
been writing and trying to
pitch shows and come up with ideas and
do things and um doing the podcast and
trying to get people to
join patreon and uh listen to the
podcast what are you been doing bud
editing the [ __ ] podcast [ __ ]
podcast
well you know this week's really i
thought this was really great to get
kiefer sutherland and jason patrick over
here
and they both have you know they come
from hollywood royalty i mean
jason's dad was the the priest the head
priest in uh
jason miller and exorcist just brilliant
and um won a pulitzer for uh that
championship season
oh yeah championship season right yeah
yeah yeah the play the play and just
uh you know of course keefer
sutherland's dad donald sutherland and
just uh two amazing guys and they they
were really uh they gave a lot of
insight into this world and we talked
lost boys we talked about family we
talked about
a lot of stuff so i think you're gonna
really enjoy this so without further ado
why don't we get inside
kiefer sutherland and jason patrick it's
my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you
with michael rosenbaum
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you guys met obviously in lost boys
right we did yeah did you meet like in
how did you meet do you remember the day
you met i i don't
specifically remember the day i know it
was up in
we shot the film in two places we shot
it in los angeles and we shot it in
santa cruz in the very very beginning
and
and in santa cruz it felt very
disjointed
uh there were two units uh it didn't
feel as
cohesive an experience for me at least
uh when we got back to los angeles so i
know
kind of when i met jason it was like hi
this is jason he's playing
and it's like hello and here's your mark
and hey
well nice really nice meeting you man
i'm i'm thrilled to be working with you
okay
and look over there and okay rolling
just like that
it was kind of like that and i remember
we became
he's looking at like well i remembered a
little differently remember well
he's right in that it was disjointed and
it really probably was just
a handshake hello but i do remember that
i actually had my birthday up there
because my birthday is on june 17th and
i turned 20
and they'd made me a cake uh i guess it
was me on a motorcycle or something like
that
and everyone said happy birthday and all
that and i specifically remember
kiefer coming up and taking the knife
and just cutting my head off for his
piece of the cake
take him and walk away now that was
before we worked together
and then the first day that we actually
worked together is the first day those
characters meet in the film
yeah yeah on the motorcycle yes did you
hit it off right away or was there you
know there's always that thing i hope
this guy is [ __ ] cool i hope he's not
a hothead he's into that by the end of
that night i think
yeah i think so too i mean at night i
really appreciated the fact
when i first read the script of lost
boys um
you know i came from the world of
get whatever job you can and just deal
with it later
right uh but lost boys was written for
much younger characters
uh they weren't supposed to be in their
20s they were all supposed to be kind of
peter panish 13 12 13 year olds
and and joel had made the change
that he wanted it to be kind of 20 kind
of early 20s and
and stuff like that and so a lot of the
dialogue had to change and i really
appreciated
how seriously jason
took it you know that he was there to
try and make the best film he could
this wasn't i need this much money to
get me to my next job
this was how do we make this really cool
and special and so
he did a lot of you know joel schumacher
who uh
we both kind of love and adored but he
did a lot of the battling with joel
uh kind of on behalf of the rest of us
to make
the script what it ultimately became and
and and
justifying certain actions for our
characters etc etc and so
i really appreciated that he took the
lead on that and that he was kind of an
adult
serious actor uh because a lot of the
stuff that i had done i'd done with very
young people like
stand by me was with 11 12 year olds who
were amazing
by the way and they were fantastic and
you were young too
i was 18 19 yeah yeah i was a year i was
a year younger than jason
and so you guys would get uh as a as a
collective
you and amy amy gertz jamie jamie
jamie gertz yeah [ __ ] me you know i make
mistakes
but you guys would all get together and
go this this this and you'd be the guy
the point man
to sort of talk to joel about it i think
sometimes but it was more that
i spent a lot of time with joel because
he tried to give me the movie for a long
time
and once we started going because i had
a lot to do
it was always about the peace whoever
else was in it
so if i felt that there was an issue
that it wasn't quite working it was more
going to jameer going to kiefer and so
what do you feel about this
or this i would never speak for them and
then uh
then i would take the lead and go in
there and say look
you know and i gotta say look lost boys
has lost boys because of joel
now i'm not and when i say that i mean
he got the guy who shot raging bull and
taxi driver
michael chapman you know that guy
doesn't come off that and shoot teen
vampire movies but joel got him
he got bo welch was an amazing
production designer
and then he got all these actors he'd
get diane wiest right off an oscar
ed herman bernard hughes you know and
young guys like me and kiefer
um so and he would be open to those
ideas
and open to dialogue and to make it
interesting and different i think the
reason the movie has lasted is because
of that effort and because of the
involvement of the people that he picked
and our relationship as adversaries
grew but as i said after that first
night we were thick pals for the next
day did you guys go out a lot did you
party
we used to go out we'd go out for lunch
and our makeup
you got to tell that story we were
sitting here
driving off the warner brothers a lot in
his convertible
it was an old 1970 911 t it was an old
old porsche
um and and we were in full vampire
makeup but we had
we just couldn't have any more of the
catering lunch and we just wanted to go
get a burger or something and so we'd
pulled out who's with you
me just me and jason just to you yeah in
full vampire makeup and these girls
pulled up
and i guess we've been like we've been
wearing the makeup so long that we
forgot it was on yeah we couldn't see it
in each other
and the two girls in the car next to us
we were like hey how you doing and they
just looked they did not appreciate it
as they called us a variety of names and
squealed out literally the light turns
green we're looking over
it's 19 year olds in the porsche and
everything and right when the light
turned greens they just look at us and
say
pigs pigs yeah and drove right off yeah
perfect yeah that's a perfect day it's a
perfect lunch
yeah we laughed about it for a while the
look on their faces was worth a million
because then we were silent what the
hell was that because you didn't
register and then we were looking at
each other going oh
yeah i mean look it's a stupid question
but like i've been on projects where i
go oh this is gonna be good
this is gonna be a big big piece of [ __ ]
did you
think this is gonna be big didn't have
the experience to
to know yeah uh you know i look back on
that time and whether it was lost boys
or stand by me
or even flatliners which joel
directed as well
those experiences kind of start to shape
what you think
when you're going through another
experience oh this might have a shot
but it was such early days for me i
can't speak for jason but for me it was
such an early time
that you just did the best you could
with the job and you were grateful to
have the job and
uh i had never experienced a huge
hit i don't think stand by me had come
out before
uh lost boys started shooting so
i it didn't even cross my phone were
having fun as a kid yeah just
and not even as a kid i mean i i took it
very seriously i was living on my own
and
uh you know
um it wasn't even as a kid it was it was
the beginning
of what i knew the rest of my life was
going to be or at least i wanted it to
be
and so that was really exciting all
right about you jay
uh you know we're shooting for the sky i
know that i know that i was determined
um to make the best uh coming-of-age
beach vampire
movie ever made and uh honestly
you have to understand that and you've
made
movies in the genre we had high level
people
as young as young men working with us as
i said michael chapman
the sets um uh so it was a perfect storm
yeah and look you know soundtracks
weren't everywhere like they are today
that lost boy soundtrack people still
play so
it was a meshing of all these things but
once again
joel's greatest strength as a director
is seeing talent
and not being intimidated by that he
welcomes it all in because he's gonna
create this collage and you have a big
say in that collage
and as young you know man that was only
the second thing i'd ever done
um that's a lot to say to have that's a
lot to say yeah
in a big move and a big uh studio movie
that's important
right i mean when somebody's helming the
ship it's
if you see any cracks or he's nervous
about
or he can't it bleeds through
right have you felt that before like
this guy doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
doing oh gosh yeah
yeah it's got to be the worst feeling as
a director but worse as an actor because
you're like
we're gonna fall we're gonna we're gonna
[ __ ] sing oh there's ways there's
ways around it and
the trick is to try and be as helpful as
you can when you
you know when you realize that someone's
inexperienced is going to be problematic
you know because there's some people
that are inexperienced and find a new
way
you know and that's really exciting and
cool but there's some people that don't
they get lost
and if you can help them out it's easier
than complaining about it
um but joel did joel joel was an
incredibly confident guy
and again had a sense of
i think he had a sense of the future or
what was coming down the line or
how to be a part of it than most people
uh
and whether you like those films or not
you know when
you can't argue with the fact that three
of his films are arguably
uh you know benchmarks for 80s
filmmaking
yeah have you guys ever been intimidated
by another actor or a director
where you could actually feel that
intimidation i'm intimidated by jason
daly
still is i'm glad he said it that's why
i get his autograph i mean you've worked
with somebody
you've worked with some of the biggest
names i mean both of you i mean you've
been around at your
hollywood royalty i mean you're you know
you it's you got to think there's
somewhere along the line where you're
like you
i mean was it was a few good man with
nicholson was that was great
that was i mean that was the only time
i've ever gone to work
um and actually half our cast
went into work on their day off because
the only two people working that day
were jack nicholson and tom cruise
and i just sneak in the back of the
courtroom set and i just want to see
and then i look around and every other
actor on the show and a couple others i
think bruce willis
uh because he was with the me and uh
yeah it was the gallery was just full of
people and he did that in two takes
the big one yeah you can't handle the
truth it was two takes he did the whole
scene
in two takes uh and he had such a great
way of learning it he would record
he would read it and record it on a tape
and then he would just play the tape in
his car
forever until he had to go do the scene
and and the dialogue
he just memorized it it was it was a
part of him
and so when he went to go do that scene
i mean he just blew the room away
and it was the first time i'd ever seen
it and rob reiner just said well
there's nothing else we can do with that
thank you very much and he wrapped
everybody early
uh that whole speech yeah
you need me on that line you want me
that was what two takes the entire
scene which is it's got to be 15
to 20 pages it's the whole crescendo of
the film did it in two takes
but you weren't intimidated by him no
because he made a point
to make sure i mean i i certainly knew
who i was working with
um but he made such a gracious point of
making sure i felt comfortable and
welcome and
and uh jt walsh was on that film who has
since passed uh i was friends with him
he was great friends with
mr nicholson and so so yeah i i've i've
found that the people that i've worked
with that are worthy of being
intimidated
are also really kind and go out of their
way to make sure you feel comfortable so
that you can do your best work with them
wow jason about you i mean you worked
with gene hackman didn't you
i worked with hackman i worked with uh
duvall
i mean that those guys seemed like
hackman seems like he'd be difficult
he's one of my favorites but he seems
like he'd be like you know he had a
limited
uh few days on geronimo and i gotta say
like kiefer said one of the first things
he came up to me and said
that he had seen a movie of mine or two
of them
that he really liked this and that
helped and that helped out
um and but i don't you know i don't
that did help but i i i was excited to
work with people like it's like playing
you want to play with tennis
with people that are good and it was a
similar situation that keeper said when
i did sleepers because hoffman and
deniro were wearing it
and they'd never acted together because
you know this is back in 93 or 94
so of course everyone showed up and it
was in a courtroom
so in the same thing everybody was in
the gallery and
it was funny because levinson was the
director barry levinson and for the
first few takes it was almost like no
one was acting
he sort of had to stop and then call
them over and say
it's okay let's let's act they were all
everyone was underplaying everybody
um but uh i don't know i mean no
i liked it look if the person in front
of you the more
real they are the more inventive they
are
that gives you better choices it's
better to play off that it's better to
reflect off that i've always felt that
what do what if you have an actor that
you look up to that's just brilliant
that is just like you're going this is
[ __ ] terrible
this person's just [ __ ] [ __ ] the
bed in front of me and no that's
exactly what i felt when i did that that
guest star on smallville
because lex luthor had always been my
hero
yeah yeah so i mean that's had to happen
where you're one of your icons and the
guys like and no one's given direction
like this is not gonna be good i i
in all fairness i i'm i'm i'm not trying
to be politically correct i have not had
that experience
um you know i i think for me over the
course of my career
sometimes maybe i've misjudged the
quality of the material
i think we all have you know i think and
that's no one's fault but mine right um
but the actors that i've worked with uh
you know not only have i been really
lucky and fortunate to work with some
incredible actors that
everybody knows and that are huge icons
and and they were not disappointing they
were
phenomenal at what they did i've worked
with day players
that'll blow your hair back i mean that
are really
great um you know uh
that's as exciting as anything it is
exciting because you're also never going
to see those day players again yeah
and you you get in there with a a day
player
and you know every day you go to work
i'm going to dance
and to have a good dancing partner wow
you know and it's real by the way that's
the hardest to be a day player and come
on and not be like this is a family and
all of a sudden you're stepping in and
being great yeah and and so experiences
like 24 and designated survivor
really allowed me to have that kind of
moment with other actors a lot
and i valued those moments as much as
anything
you know period uh and i was just like
man this guy or this
this woman is just kicking the [ __ ] out
of what is maybe not a very
great scene is just kind of you know get
us to point a to point b
and they nailed it and they killed it
and i've just
those are the moments that i remember
that i really really do love what i do
you go out of your way sometimes to say
hey
i just want to say that was great if i
see someone who does something that i
think is great i will be the
i will do everything i can to make sure
they know
and by the way that goes far i mean
people love hearing that [ __ ]
well if they've put the work in and you
can see it they deserve it
you know and and and so again
you know my experience with actors has
been pretty extraordinary and and i know
i've been really lucky because
i've sat at a bar more than once or
twice and heard the stories of some of
the crap that goes on
i just haven't run into a whole lot of
it right jay
uh i think i've been pretty lucky i mean
i haven't worked as much through the
years as kiefer because there's a while
there where
i would just be selective in every year
every two years
just not work so usually the projects i
was involved in early on especially were
stuff that i had a lot of
say in so uh i worked with the people i
wanted to work with
and and i got to work with directors
where once again i had
a lot of input but i've definitely had
difficulties i mean anyone would
it's it's it's a business filled with
narcissists and vanity and
i mean keith and i have been in it for
35 years so there's going to be
there's going to be difficulties and
there's going to be things that
i don't know make it more difficult to
get it up these days
for me literally and figuratively well
certainly
certainly working-wise i don't know
keeper's different that way he can get
into a mode and
and uh and really chug it out but
uh i i in all honesty i'd be a little
more dispirited i think
you regret being more selective being
too selective at one point in your life
um i don't regret it because uh
it led to certain projects that i'm
proud of
do i think that selectivity has
a respect and integrity that ended up
working in my favor
probably not i mean the business changed
so much it really became about
uh fame and how many titles you have and
things like that and
i mean i can remember even back i mean
geez
when i did narc and i mean narc was on a
shoestring budget there was nobody
and then carnahan and uh and leota
you know they met me wanted me to do it
and there was a nothing company making
it
and this was back in 2000 and they
didn't want me because they literally
said i didn't have enough
videos on the uh video shelf and
jesus and i'll give it to carnahan i
mean he said at the time look i'm gonna
at least meet with uh
with patrick i don't know if he's gonna
do it but if you're not gonna let me
meet then you know we're not making the
movie so
i mean that those are the kind of
difficulties that came from that now
there would be some people who would
stand up like that
but once again um i hadn't worked for
three years before narc because i
i did your friends and neighbors which i
had produced
so but i also got to say i've always
looked at different points in my life is
what is this project
going to bring to me what can i give at
22 what can i give it 35 what can i do i
have something to say with this director
with this project because i really just
looked at having a life
honestly i never really tried to build a
career and i think now maybe that bites
a little in the butt but i wanted to
live life
and these these these stories that we'd
ultimately act in for me anyway
we're going to be a part of that life so
that's the way i approached it not
what would be the next the next best
move so you still he's so full of it
[Laughter]
why is he full of he was he was patient
he'd find the right film to do
he basically liked having lunch with me
and hearing me go man i really wanted to
do that film did you like making
it and whether it was belly of the beast
or rush
or you know those were the jobs that
everybody wanted
i mean and you have to understand you
know
robert de niro who was probably
the actor that anyone in the early 80s
kind of wanted to emulate
certainly in the kind of career and work
they were doing in that situation you
did maybe one film every three years
that you know i remember telling my
daughter when she started i said you
want to have the perfect career
do two films one in your 20s and then
one in your 40s
and then and then be done you know and
and everybody will call you a real
artist
um and it's the truth and i think at a
very early age
and as much as i believe there is an
artistry to it
uh this was how i was going to raise my
kids and i had kids when i was really
young
yeah i was 19. and so i
took a left turn and jason went straight
you know and and i think you know i've
always taken my hat off to jason
uh because there was a credibility
factor that he had that i don't think
anybody uh you know
or or you know the gary oldmans at that
time did and the sean pans
but it was that that was a
that was a tricky wire to walk
um so i always took my hat off to that
and i thought it was really courageous
inside of you is brought to you by
better help better help
online therapy uh you know you guys hear
this
every episode and uh you know how
important it is and if you're
questioning it or you're thinking about
it i'm urging you to
seek therapy get therapy because it's
helped me and it's helped millions of
people around the world
um that is just a true statement i don't
have to try and sell that one you know
what is therapy i think therapy is
anything you guys want it to be
um but for me it's it's it's talking to
someone who i can trust that's not
that's not a friend that's not a family
member that can be objective
that i could feel like i could tell them
all my thoughts and
get a professional opinion and how to
work things out
and i think that's what better help is
all about whether you have you know
stress issues anxiety issues temper
dealing with insecurities there's so
many
different things that we all face
and better help is there it's time you
stop being ashamed of normal human
struggles and start feeling better
because you deserve to be happy better
help is a customized online therapy that
offers video
phone even live chat sessions with your
therapist so
you don't have to see anyone on camera
if you don't want to know i like to see
someone because that's how i roll
but you don't have to if you're shy or
if you're like i'm thinking about
therapy
then you know maybe you just talk to
them without the camera on but you could
also text them and do other things it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy i
i could tell you that by experience i
mean if you want to spend hundreds and
hundreds of dollars each session
then you can go do that if you want but
better help is far cheaper than any of
these
and you can get a therapist in under 48
hours join the millions of people who
are seeing what therapy is really about
it may or may not be for you but it's
worth looking into because you're your
greatest asset
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and inside of you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp betterhelp.com
inside i never really understand why you
know
you hear about oh well what happened to
that person or what happened you mean
they're a great actor and they're
available and they you know
it's you know i've had these
conversations with you where it's like
you know you were so selective and then
you went off and i don't know pretty
much
got your son back for many years
and there's that whole story but it's
not like you go anywhere it's not like
your talent escapes you
but it's got to be frustrating sometimes
when you're like not being considered
for certain things it's like you know
what the [ __ ] happened what time
time happened yeah time happens father
you know father time undefeated well
it's not so much that you're not being
considered people just think
you're impossible to get you know so
it's a double-edged
sword and it's it's uh yeah you know but
i think you have to look at the root of
why the decision was made and i
i will always have huge respect for you
know the films that jason's made and the
choices that he's made
and i'm not joking every year we'd have
a meal
man i really wanted that film
congratulations
what was it like to make that you know i
was just watching for uh your friends
and neighbors
and i that scene in the shower or it's
like a five-minute
push-in on jason's character and i'm
just like
it's one of the most powerful like even
if you don't want to watch it or listen
to it or you're doing
tweeting and doing you're so drawn to it
that i am just
completely focused on that it was one of
the most amazing monologues like i've
ever seen
it really truly was like i'm sure you're
aware of that no thank you thank you
and i mean let me guess kiefer was two
takes uh
i wasn't there for that i know i know i
know actually uh you know one of the
reasons i think it was so well written
by neil labute and
as i said i produced it and put it
together and cast it and i said to him
uh everything was filmed on location
except obviously that we built that one
uh steam room and i said you got a bill
i i never wanted to tell him how to
direct
i said this has to be one take build a
long dolly and just come to me and i'm
not saying it for me
i'm saying for your language you don't
want to break away from it
and he wanted in a way to make the
longest monologue in american film at
the time
but as you know the content of it is so
difficult to try to pull off
because of where i couldn't believe what
i was hearing yeah so and and once again
to go back to we were saying earlier the
degree of difficulty like a dive i love
that
we rehearsed every scene we did that
movie like a
like a play with three weeks of
rehearsal five days a week
culminated with a three-day retreat in a
house we got in arrowhead
now you could never do that with actors
today to get me katherine keener
uh ben stiller and assassin kinskier and
eckhart myself
and the thing was if one doesn't show up
nobody shows up
and don't forget there's no iphones then
no one brings their kids
so when we started we were ready ready
to go and the one scene that we never
ever rehearsed was that steam room scene
jesus by the way i'm getting
uncomfortable because uh i know this
kiefer's been looking around at all
these posts he's like what the [ __ ]
wrong with this guy
no no have you know did you not notice
one over your left shoulder
yeah i saw that as i sat down no always
just take in one's environment
how do you feel about that how do you
feel about actors getting autographs
from other actors
people collect baseball cards cars you
know
i mean if for whatever reason if
if it's something that that you dig
you don't do it you don't have any
autographs do you yeah i signed for him
before he got up here
yeah i got jason's autograph yeah he
does that's about it
that's about it i think i'm looking
around at the posters kind of
remembering
when they had posters yeah i remember uh
when we were doing young guns
we we were doing young guns one and the
first thing we shot was the trailer
is that true yeah we shot the trailer
shot for shot
the very first day the trailer was us
coming over the
hill and all of us raising our weapons
and firing into the camera
and then it went young guns you know
february
1987 or whatever it was
and we shot the trailer and then we went
straight from that
and we all shot the poster
i remember looking at lou diamond
phillips and when i
i hope no one [ __ ] dies
and he went why and i said well because
they won't be held they've put out the
trailer saying you know
we're doing stuff on horseback we're
doing this that yeah there's no digital
erasing a lot of accidents can happen
here
and if some if someone were not able to
complete that film
the whole ad campaign is just shot to
hell so
we started in a time when the poster and
the trailer
were as important as anything
and in the case of young guns in their
someone's
executive's opinion more important than
the film
which i thought was hysterical because
there were news there were newspapers
there's no newspapers on newspapers
when you got that big full-time ad i
remember with lost boys now look
that's a classic poster and that's all
joel yeah warner brothers didn't know
what to do with this movie
and the movie did good it became huge on
video but that's all joel
he put that whole thing together and
that wasn't a shot he took pieces from
things
uh photo shoots pieces from the film he
did the poster oh yeah old joe
that's all joe everything they had
sucked warner brothers had no idea what
they were doing
that's all him but keeper's right there
was also there's a romance
to uh the old posters as you know
because you have them here and it's the
same thing with the trailer
and we talked about this before i mean i
think that we both
find that we're lucky that we're been
around a lot
around long enough that we experienced
when it was a big deal when a movie
opened
yeah because there weren't a hundred of
them and there was no streaming
and you knew from the trailer that this
movie was coming out in a few months
or whatever your favorite movie was and
premieres were real
so we had that last sort of wave of that
hollywood history
and also being part of films like lost
boys that didn't have digital effects
and it makes a
big difference yeah if you i mean back
in the day if you had a premiere in
westwood
that was it there was a shot you were
going to do pretty well and definitely
get laid at least
yeah without question although i think i
screwed that up too
well let's say almost definitely
definitely look you both come from
hollywood royalty and i've seen so many
like documentaries and i've seen the
true hollywood story whatever the you
know you've
done all these interviews and stuff but
like growing up like i grew up with a
guy who
was a manager at a pharmaceutical plant
who worked his ass off and
you know i didn't see him all that often
until he came home and you know
we have we had dysfunction in my family
for sure like everybody else but
i couldn't imagine you know you know
your father
late father jason miller was a pulitzer
prize winner he
he was the priest everybody knows the
priest and the exorcist which was like
unbelievable performance in that he was
a great actor and of course your
father's donald sutherland so
it's like there's no [ __ ] way that
it's easy
because your fathers are probably both
out they're all doing their things
they're having careers and like being a
kid it's got to affect you as a kid
there's no doubt
uh not having him around all the time
and so i mean but growing up
a sutherland growing up uh you know i
guess like a miller
at the time at the time i mean how how
difficult was that and
is it something that you know because i
have stuff that happened from charlotte
and you let
things go i'm an adult you know
my father i've talked about he's never
capable of saying i love you i'm proud
of you
good job i've never heard those words
even still even still you don't hear
those words
you don't hear them that's just not his
but i've learned that that's just to
you know he can't do that that's not who
he is and
i and i forgive him i love him but as a
kid
not hearing you're really good or
you're smart i love you those are
[ __ ] difficult things not to hear
so i'm just wondering did you guys hear
that stuff
was that the constant or is it something
you always were chasing or
was it hard growing up i had a great
childhood i mean i honestly
have a pretty awesome life actually um
you know i didn't grow up with my dad i
grew up with my mom right uh
a great theater actor uh
every night after school have to go to
the theater do our homework
uh wait till the play performance was
over and then we'd all go home
so i was around the theater a great deal
that's where i started
that's where we ended um
you know so and as a kid you just what
you get is what you know
so i didn't have any trauma or drama
or you know and yeah my dad was was
working and and i think
probably one of the most prolific
important careers in
english language you know and i'm his
son and i'm hugely proud of him
uh did we spend a lot of time together
no
um do i understand it absolutely
yeah um and we tried to make up for it
as years went by you know did that work
out
yeah yeah i mean it's our thing is our
thing and it's it is what it is
so you know but i'm hugely proud of him
i
think he's an incredibly smart sometimes
very very funny guy
um and he's a brilliant brilliant actor
and was really important
uh i think to cinema and so
it's what it is it also allowed me at a
very early age to go i'm gonna do what i
want
you know because everybody else did so i
found that to be really helpful
yeah i always felt like there was a
little competition with my dad and i
like there was always like
you know when i was an actor and he's
working his ass off and making
you know go to school and study and run
a plan i was like oh you're making all
this money being an actor that's not
[ __ ] work
i mean obviously he was an actor so you
were both doing the same thing but did
you ever feel like there was a
competition
no no no no it was i mean
it was interesting for me things
timing timing worked out
my father had moved to france and
decided to take
a few years off he has three younger
sons
with a different mother or wife
and uh so he took you know a sabbatical
for
really almost a decade and that was
right when we started doing
lost boys in our and my film so
and i've asked him he didn't do it on
purpose but he left a window open for me
that i thought was
you know pretty cool and
and so yeah so i never felt that i just
uh
i'm sure you've had your moments no i
mean i
i honestly i'm thrilled when he's happy
with the stuff that he's done
uh and i'm thrilled when things are
going really well for him
uh and equally i'm grateful for the
opportunities i've had
and he commends you he'll call you after
something i love that yeah
yeah and you do the same yeah yeah
absolutely wow
how did it affect or did it affect how
you raised your kids
you growing up with an absent father did
it have a change
well it's not so much
no because i mean i worked and i made a
point of of kind of being in the same
town as my daughter i think the biggest
change for me was
i got divorced uh from my daughter's
mother
when my daughter was quite young and i
think i made a point of handling the
divorce in a certain way
that i didn't that i didn't think either
of my parents
did that very well uh so i i made a
point of really
trying to do that well
and camilla and i are still really close
friends
uh to this day we still have
thanksgiving and christmases together
so i think we've done that about as well
as as you can
it's not something i'm recommending for
anybody out there
uh try and avoid divorce that's right
and uh
you know i'm i love camilla and always
will and it's why we got married
uh and we were lucky enough to be able
to kind of take care of each other
um financially and in other ways which
is generally what makes people
kind of go crazy it makes it easier on
the kid though when your friends
certainly you know certainly doesn't and
in the you know
the one person in the group that didn't
get to make any of these choices is the
poor child
so sarah yeah yeah and and she's
extraordinary and michelle
and uh so you yeah so that was probably
you know in looking back at as a parent
looking back
on my life if there was one kind of
moment that i tried to
do differently uh it would be divorce
hmm you got to tell them the uh your
wedding story and then i want to hear
you about your
you have to you tell them about your dad
no what about the wedding story
no no it's it's uh i was very young
uh we were all young and jason was
worried that
that i wasn't making a very good choice
and
he had offered up his companionship and
basically said you know if you start
running right now i'll run with you
and uh he said this at the wedding yeah
well we were in the backyard and i said
no i'm i'm good man i'm good thank you
though
there was a big wall in the back and
there was lots of people there's a lot
of drunk people and a lot of
people on other substances and we're
just talking and
just in a wistful way looked at that
wall and said to kiever is it
you see that wall we run to that wall we
climb that wall we just keep running
and we just shared a little laugh about
that well what about you though with
your with your dad i know i mean
it was different different than kiefer's
because my dad
had a brilliant burst and then that was
it
as kiefer said his dad had a much more
sustained career
and and was famous my dad i i never
felt fame in my in in my family i mean
we were very poor
uh lived poor for a while um and
my mother's father was a wealthy man but
gave nothing
jackie gleason right your mother's
father was jackie gleason
right but you guys were poor absolutely
so jackie was
jackie gleason at the time tipping
doorman hundred-dollar bills but you
know meanwhile
you know uh hot dogs for thanksgiving
for his daughter and
and her husband yeah and kids what was
there a reason behind that
i don't know what the reason was to
honest to be honest to god i
i met gleason twice in my life so um
i think there was probably an actor idea
uh that he didn't approve of which is
strange because he was and he came from
great poverty
but my dad wrote that championship
season
and then became a very big success had
never been in a movie
and got hired in the exorcist which is a
story for another day it's a
great story how he got that so you know
he went from cashing three dollar checks
at the bank
to in a year and a half when he appealed
surprise being nominated for an oscar in
the biggest movie of all time
and he's a kid ultimately aside from his
talent from
scranton pennsylvania coal mine and uh
he couldn't handle it so that was as
great as it was lifting us out of
poverty and all this wondrous stuff that
was the end of dad because he was gone
after that
well what about i gotta i'm thinking
about jackie now there's all this
success did jackie come back into the
picture
absolutely he did oh yeah and
absolutely because they wanted to make
movie versions of
uh that championship season so gleason
then wanted to play the coach
and i think that's the point that my dad
said go [ __ ] yourself
uh which he had every right to do um
look
it there's a lot of crazy you know
shakespearean
fear and vengeance and anger in our
business and
i can't explain why as a father i can't
explain why you wouldn't help your child
i i don't know but that was the case
look from my dad's standpoint
it made him you know delivering welfare
checks and driving cabs and being a
waiter
it made him um uh say
i have to be a success and i think i
told kiefer this when we were doing the
play
that he came home one day we lived in
flesh and queens and i was pushing my
brother on a broken down playground in
this
building we lived in he said he came up
the uh
the subway stairs he looked at us and i
was pushing my brother and he said he
started to cry he said i'm getting them
out of here
and he went up in the elevator and he
started writing that championship season
that day
wow and so you know you d you you go
with what you go with
and what was your relationship with him
was it pretty i mean
it was definitely oh no definitely
fraught because he was because he was
gone
um had you know major we've talked
about you know your dad i don't know but
mine had major alcohol issues and drugs
and the truth is when he had this
amazing sort of comet ball of fame and
couldn't
take it we lived back east then he moved
california
you know bought a porsche sort of lived
his james dean fantasies out and
sort of sadly pissed away
this amazing amazing career that he had
because at the time championship season
was the longest running
broadway show since streetcar named
desire
and he was gives one of the penultimate
performances
in the exorcist the 70s performance
movie doesn't work without him
so he can write his own parts in his own
ticket
and he just got caught up in the typical
uh uh hollywood sort of downturn the
spiral
so from that you know as a young man you
look up to your father
and you also need him to be there but in
some edible sort of way when i decided
to do what i wanted to do
i just cut that line man and wanted to
become my own person
and so i never talked about him or my
grandfather or any of those things in
the early days
ever how was the relationship towards
the end before he um passed
did you kind of salvage things a little
bit there was times
where we were strange for a while but
towards the end yes i mean
because you just have to look at for
them as you said this is who they are
you know you're going to change them
it's crazier for us to think that we're
going to change our parents
this is all he could do i mean in 1938
you're born in there and
you if you want to have sex you marry
someone right then you have kids you're
not ready to do anything and then you
all of a sudden follow
your passions or your mistakes your
demons and so you have to see
you know who they are look doing the
play
all those years later not only reignited
my
uh uh relationship with kiefer which you
know i love like a brother
but it also in the court battle later on
because i did that play and i did it in
new york that's why i got
uh gus back so in some karmic way
for everything he did if i didn't do
that play at that moment
you know and have my son visit me at at
that moment
that piece of evidence that i used i
never would have won
and when you and kiefer did that
championship season in 2011
yeah yeah did you you said something
about didn't you take some of his ashes
i had his urn for some ashes and i just
put it on the stage
as part of the as part of the things i
figured i knew he would love this cast
and figure he might as well put him up
there what was that experience like
i know it was short-lived but like was
it an amazing experience it wasn't that
short
we did two couple months right seven
months with rehearsals we were there at
least five months
and we've played it we played it out we
it was
the best experience i've had because not
only we're doing this play
every night i mean i'd say to kiefer
every night he'd be in the wings but i
started the play on
on on stage alone and he'd be sitting in
this window
you know he doesn't come on for 10
minutes ready to go we do the same thing
every time
we'd give a little fist bump and say
time of our lives and he'd say go kill
it
not in my head so it's not wow when you
asked before
do you know when something is going to
be magical yes we did and even if it
wasn't we wanted to appreciate all that
moment
right yeah it was it was a definitely
was not a short time
and it was a but it was
it was a an incredibly balanced cast
and and everybody went for it
you know it was it was i miss
the film industry the
my experience in the 80s where you know
you would go
shoot a movie up in oregon and the
entire cast and crew would move into a
hotel
and you take over the bar and
and you just it was it was a very
communal experience much more fraternal
and
and obviously that's changed um but when
we went to do the play
you know there was never a night that
the five of us weren't
every night out together and every night
after every show
we finished we'd go grab something to
eat have a chat visit laugh
about someone did this or that and visit
our various haunts
and it was great that's great yeah it
was awesome
inside of you is brought to you by geico
ryan what's the hardest part about
living in la
uh probably the rent rent rent is pretty
high
i would say that's the toughest thing
that people encounter all over the world
it's like you know they had that rule
right you have to make enough in one
week to pay or in two weeks to pay your
rent for the month that was
the this old rule that they had so in
other words it's
not only is it hard to pay but it's like
you know things get expensive but you
don't have time
to pay your renters insurance your
homeowners insurance and your auto
policy and all these things get piled up
and you're like
it gets overwhelming yeah right but what
if i told you that geico
had a bundling policy that would be very
interesting
you could pay for your renter's
insurance and your auto policy
all-in-one and it's just taken care of
every month and you don't have to go to
two different places how does that sound
great that's exactly what i thought
you'd say we don't have a lot of time on
our hands folks that's just the way it
is
just go to geico go to geico for god's
sakes
geico.com you just get a quote you see
how much
you could save their bundling policies
are awesome
it's geico easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com even
can do it inside of you is brought to
you by keeps
ryan two out of three men will
experience some
sort of hair loss by the time they're
35. oh
more than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer from male pattern baldness
and there are only get this two fda
approved medications that can prevent
hair loss
keeps offers both look i played a bald
guy for many years
on smallville and some people are
comfortable being bald and some people
aren't especially when you're young
you don't want to go bald too early and
there are ways to help
fix that prevent that and i have friends
certainly that are constantly
doing comb overs and talking about you
know
i gotta get plugs and i gotta get well
keeps us here folks
keeps offers a simple stress free way
to keep your hair convenient virtual
doctor consultations and medications
delivered straight to your door
every three months you don't have to
leave your home and you don't you know
how i don't like to leave my home
low cost treatments start at just ten
dollars per month
and keeps offers generic versions
discreet packaging and proven results
keeps says more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results
so act fast if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss
go to keeps dot com keps.com
inside of you to receive your first
month of treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash inside of you to get your first
month free
keeps dot com
slash inside of you
i always look at you and i'm like when
you were on
jack bauer for 24 and the one thing i
always look at because my [ __ ] mind
goes there you know me
i'm like god how does he learn all those
lines how does he [ __ ] work that much
the guy who's always working why does he
work so much
are you someone that just has to work
i've asked this question other actors i
just i
i enjoy it you really enjoy it 24 was
was an incredible experience uh
it was the closest thing i've had to a
regular or real job
and and and i've had actor friends of
mine
you know who were really nervous about
doing television
and and i spoke glowingly of it and then
they went and did it and hated it
you know they hated the repetition they
hated
i for whatever reason uh i
didn't feel that way about that
character i didn't feel that way about
the show
um you know if you want what i ended up
walking away from with that
is is you know if if you want to go to
the olympics
and be a sprinter you train you know and
for me as an actor
to be able to work five days a week 11
months a year
you're going to learn some [ __ ] and i
did how do you train for that
what do you do what do you do to prepare
for something well no i mean i mean
you train with the regular things that
you would do as an actress so
you know after after a certain amount of
time you start to realize your ability
to absorb dialogue
uh so that is exponentially improved you
you realize that your ability to walk
onto a set and figure out how to block a
scene
exponentially improves because you're
doing it every day
and when we started we were doing you
know sometimes a film a year
which is just a few months so it
it taught me a lot and i loved doing it
uh is it for everybody oh my god no
because the people that i told them you
know you'll love it do it
they [ __ ] hate me they
they didn't like it and uh you know it's
not for
everybody uh but i do i have always
liked working
uh you know you guys talked about gene
hackman's my favorite actor
yeah i've never met him i've never
worked with him
very jealous of that um you know he
would do eight films in
a year you know whereas robert de niro
would do one and a half movies every
three years
but de niro would do that in the first
15 years yeah you know now you will see
him now he does eight movies yeah yeah
yeah but gene hackman literally did i
remember
the closest i ever felt to gene hackman
was one year i did more movies than he
did
yeah you threw yourself a party yeah
eight movies in a year
he did yeah gene hackman obviously if
he's done that many movies there's
probably a lot of gene heckman movies i
always assumed everything he was in was
great oh no no
well but these these were one of them
was the package
there there were some great films but
look he had i think three ex-wives which
is one of the reasons he's doing
a lot of movies he could be part of he
was also you know
invasion of the killer bees but he was
[ __ ] great in it
not a good movie but he was great like
the thing i've always admired about
you know gene hackman and the poseidon
adventure the guy does not have a false
moment no
the film might not be great but boy he's
just
i've never seen anybody that watchable
and that can that can take me from point
a to point b
easier uh i just he's
a marvel and the most believable temper
yeah when he loses his [ __ ] what was
that postcards from the edge
you go home and you get your [ __ ]
together yeah and he just loses his mind
for a second i'm just like
whoa he can go zero to 70 better yeah
that's explosive and i i don't you don't
see that very often somebody that could
just go
the [ __ ] up yeah and just snap like that
i i really
i mean you take a look at even the
performance that he gave
in uh bonnie and clyde which was so
nuanced um
i mean he's kind of playing the
the hick dumb hick in the back of the
car
and and kind of bemused by words and
what he doesn't understand it's just
the delicacy uh that
because he's a brutish kind of guy the
delicacy with which he can do some of
that work is really
i also like guys i mean as keeper said
bru and he was a marine
and guys like that that come from
something so totally different
i mean we both understood somewhat what
theater was what acting was
doesn't mean we'd have to find our own
ways but it wasn't a foreign concept
i just love the idea how some big galoot
who is a marine and then somehow
stumbles into the business
and brings that but it was also one of
the
one of the qualities of those great 70s
films
that a guy like gene hackman who looks
like gene hackman a guy like elliot
gould a guy like donald sutherland
a guy like al pacino could be major
worldwide movie stars and
very hard to believe that that could
happen today well yeah i mean
the two biggest stars in the world
at that time were robert redford and
paul newman
so when you think of someone like my dad
i always thought he was the bravest man
in the world because at that time to go
yeah i'm gonna go become an actor
and kill it yeah really
you don't look like robert redford and
paul newman
you know and um and neither did gene
hackman eliot gould
robert duvall or pacino or hoffman yeah
so
it's it's uh because it's just acting it
was all that mattered
do you have the chops yes that's what
mattered then and that's also that
mystery
which i keeper was alluding to of doing
a film every year or so and disappearing
and then coming back into that character
that definitely influenced me
in those early choices of mine without
question well it was a big difference
i mean certainly i can reference my
father's work
uh if you wanted to go see donald
sutherland in a
in a movie you had to go to the movie
theater
there was no option to watch it at home
and so there was a big separation
between
film and television uh
hbo the movie channels back in the 80s
that started to blur the line
uh and then the internet just debunked
you know even more than that it wasn't
just if you wanted to see a donald
sutherland movie if you wanted to see
donald sutherland's face mm-hmm you had
to go to a movie fighter
yeah same thing with the denier what
does he look like who knows let's go see
yeah and i always thought that why it
was so powerful is when you did show up
you got to learn about them through that
yeah not this mindless crap that
everybody has to do
i got to see and i've seen de niro and
letterman with
hoffman and those people it's completely
boring to me it's not interesting
um and they're uncomfortable uh but to
see
the movie to just point out that jason
said that not me
i knew that was extraordinary
kiefer loved you on letterman i did
yeah uh no it's not interesting to me
and it's not just him other actors
i'm much it's much more interesting to
me and i'm much more involved watching
them in what they do
as opposed to satisfying and these days
satisfying all this
mindless platform junk um
to me it waters down the power of of
everybody's gifts and you can make the
musical reference of
you know david bowie was the perfect
example of what you're describing
is david bowie didn't even stay in the
same kind of genre
musically aesthetically so you never
really knew who he was and
and the mystery of who he was was as
exciting as
the product that he was making right uh
what was that album cover going to be
and that is that is that's true that is
that has changed
the mystery is gone is what you're
saying jason what absolutely is i mean
bo is a good example but the other but
there are actors who are similar
is that the trends that were created was
coming from whatever their artistic
expression was
where they were in their life now it's
the opposite whatever the zeitgeist is
you're supposed to fold into so you can
get as many eyes as you can
and it's gone the opposite way now you
know
and that's difficult and look i have a
big problem with
uh you know social media first of all
it's a misnomer it's anti-social there's
nothing social about it
you're not socializing but the problem
is that people are appropriating other
people's lives by
what is popular and living in someone
else's virtual
now and i think it's very hard for kids
that's why you have all these studies
now that talk about the the suicide and
depression rate of people doing all that
and you know we're actors and that's the
way things
get get seen now so you have to sort of
i guess find a way to to to meld into it
i haven't been good
i've been good with it but you know also
if you're a guy like kiefer
or certain actors they don't even need
to do social media
it's not going to affect their career
their careers you know what i mean i
mean you're lucky in that
that regard but for like someone like me
or some effect jason's either i mean
well jason doesn't do any social do you
no yeah so it clearly has
more than anybody's
yeah i mean it's it's a tough one it's
like you i i hate it i hate
always feeling compelled to do it but
you got to get your nose you're showing
what you do and you're not melding by
the way kiefer's instagram or whatever
because show
is mainly about his music which is
amazing so it's not hey
here's my donut and here's my puffy pout
this is what i'm
this is what i'm about and i think that
you do a really
sort of classy uh uh very sort of
underhand way compared to everyone else
now you know man
but you have something to talk about
with that and this the music
well and the main the main benefit for
me
uh with social media look
i've been incredibly fortunate and
other people have backed me up on that
and so
you know to be able to have a moment
where you get to thank
an audience that that's true
collectively enjoyed something that you
did
man i'll take that any day of the week
um but but i agree with jason that
that it is it's unfortunate uh
you know when you get to the bullying
and you get and you see
how young people think that like the
number of young people
that i've seen said well the whole world
knows
you know what i look like naked because
someone posted this picture i'm like
well the whole world's not looking
you know i think we had to remind
ourselves back in the day that if
if a review was bad you know it was
wrapping fish the next day
and it was you know and you know
we need to kind of dial back the whole
this idea that the whole world is
interested in anything any of us really
do and just kind of take a deep breath
and go
ah but it is true that
if you make a mistake in youth or even
have an opinion
that at the time is not where the wave
of opinion is going
that is there forever and we don't have
to get into the cancer culture but that
is another thing
that and i think that's the problem of
appropriating other people's behavior
and living things
you're not able to just feel who you are
and and be able to speak
and make those mistakes or more
importantly have your opinions
change yeah i think that's your opinions
change yeah we grow we evolve
i think you said some things maybe in
the 90s maybe you didn't mean it
we say [ __ ] all the time so you
definitely have to watch them out people
get fired immediately for certain things
and it's
you know what's good though is that you
were just talking about like for someone
like kiefer who doesn't really use
social media except to talk about like
you know let people know about the band
right you love your music it's probably
your first passion
it sounds like it i mean no i love them
both i love storytelling
and so whichever kind of medium you want
to use to do that
storytelling you know uh we did that
championship season we told
jason's dad's story yeah uh
write a song about a moment or a thought
i love to do that and then
to go do a film or do a show like 24
uh it's all storytelling to me and it's
just different ways you can present that
what i love is the fact that there's a
lot of actors i have a band called
sun spin you know and i love them i love
the album that just came out we really
busted our ass but you of course people
look at you go oh actor trying to be a
musician
oh keeper southern's but then i'm like
wait a minute these guys are [ __ ] on
tour in 200 [ __ ] cities across the
country
he's got all these albums and i started
listening to it and i was like wow
not putting my band down but i was
really impressed thank you you know
and one song that really touched me was
not from this album because reckless in
me is the new album
right it is or did another record in the
pandemic but won't come out for another
few months yeah
sweet but uh i love that song from down
in the hole the album down on hold
called my best friend
yeah yeah because i just you know i i
just i felt it
i think i think we've all been there
where yeah
you kind of wake up one day and go wow
i'm the one hurting myself you know find
a way to make me my best friend
was just like that lyric you know thank
you very much great line
yeah because i always think like you
know people so many times on this
podcast or like
dude be better to yourself don't you're
not dumb
you're not you know they're all
sometimes my perception of myself and
then i listen to that song and it just
was exactly like it's like love yourself
dude [ __ ] just love your [ __ ] self
and i don't know a human being on the
planet that
hasn't needed to be told that once
you know uh or reminded uh
you know it's look it's been it's been
an interesting time
the thing that made uh kind of caught my
ear when you said you know
actor trying to be a musician i'm not
trying to be anything
i can play i can write exactly i'm not
trying to be anything you either like it
or you don't like it but i'm not
trying to be anything um and
and i'm not doing it and there is a big
difference this is not how i'm putting
food on my kids table
this is not how i'm making sure that
they're all right uh i get to do it how
i want it the way i want it
um and again uh
the first tour we ever played i was
happy anybody showed up literally if 10
people showed up i was thrilled
yeah uh the fact that more people did i
was grateful for that
um do i understand why 50 000 didn't
show up
oh my god yes you know i mean it's no
big deal
uh you know so it's it's again i think
especially at this stage in my life when
you start to realize
you got more years behind you than you
do in front
do it because you want to do it you know
if you're lucky enough to be in that
place
uh then do it
could i play one hair of the song sure
is that you playing
[Music]
most of the people that i've known that
let me down
or cause me pain most of the people that
have known me too
probably say the same
but i don't know when it got so bad
or how it hope went off track
all i know is i can't waste more time
no more looking back so
goodbye
[Music]
it's time to start again
i'll find a way
yeah i'll find a way
to make me my best friend come on
that is song writing that is pen to
paper folks
thank you very much really i really
really love it i really love it touch it
touch the soul it really did
you got to see him in concert i can't
wait really tight band and it's
really please let's go you got to see
his dancing moves
yeah i've seen i you know i looked i was
watching some concerts online i was
watching
one time you're telling a story on stage
about how you uh wrote a song for your
mom
and you told about her then she looked
at you like she was upset yeah
because well i wrote about her passing
because she had had a really bad stroke
and uh and then of course
the plane landed she had my sister had
said she wasn't going to make it so i
flew home
and she did make it and then i had this
song for a long time it was called
saskatchewan
uh and i said look i want to play this
for you so you know
what i'm going to be going through
because i thought you were going to pass
away and i wrote this
and i and i just thought maybe play it
for you so you know how much i'm going
to miss you
and i played with a song and uh
she she looked upset and i started
thinking oh my god what have i done this
is the dumbest thing
why would you do that why would you play
her this song and i start to apologize
and she says no no sweetheart
you know i don't want to be buried in
saskatchewan right
and i said yes i know it's a metaphor
that that's where you're from and she
says oh then i love it
[Laughter]
so that's amazing and my mom has since
passed so
if she can hear me now i miss you and uh
and she was she was funny like that and
so kiefer did put you in saskatchewan
i'm sorry
no i did not no he didn't hey really
quick this is called rapid fire this is
just uh patrons my fellow patrons just
asked questions you could do really fast
there it is jason have you found a new
guilty pleasure during the pandemic
if so what is it uh pickleball
have i found a guilty pleasure yeah
cooking cooking cooking uh leanne p what
character have you portrayed do you
relate
the most to i uh for me
it would be jack bauer jack bauer as
well
jack bauer yeah come on is that true who
there's got to be a character
i really could not you couldn't tell it
no all right uh
lisa h for kiefer so many great roles in
films but one of my faves was flashback
what was it like working with dennis
hopper
dennis hopper is amazing um
i'll tell you a very quick funny story
about dennis please uh
we're coming back from work one day and
and i had only known him for about two
or three days and he was getting married
or he just got married and and i had
just gotten married too but i was 19 and
he was
closer to 60. and and i was in the truck
with him and i said you know i think
it's so
cool that you waited to get married till
you absolutely knew you were with the
right person
and he looked at me and he said are you
an idiot
and i said what no why and he said
it's my fourth marriage you [ __ ]
i literally was so naive that i thought
that he had waited until he was 50
something years old
to get married because he was holding on
for the right one
i love dennis after that you canadian
you yeah
michelle k says did you keep any
souvenirs from lost boys either of you
i kept the leather jacket and the
sunglasses and then
gave them both away i think i kept the
jacket for a while and i don't know
where it is
now well you know somebody who would
like it
maisha maisha is there an artist kiefer
you'd love to jam with
and also going home is my favorite song
by all oh that's very very sweet
oh my god the list of people that i
would like to play with is is just
is ridiculous um
you know again the aspect of music that
i like the storytelling
uh i'm not the greatest guitar player
i'm certainly not the greatest singer
um but i've loved the storytelling so
there's so many different players
uh that that i would love to play with
um one of my favorite storytellers
though
just from a very early age was david
bowie i think i would have loved to had
been able to visit with him for some
time
just to talk to him about songwriting
and and and
[Music]
get a sense of how he visualized so much
of the stuff he did
yeah that would have been awesome
meeting bowie back in the day
uh cynthia i remember watching the movie
rush jason you and jennifer jason lee
were extraordinary what was the way you
approached this role and how emotionally
intense was it to portray that character
um yeah it was rough because i um
it's so totally different than me that
that type of character and someone
in that deep deep especially how old i
was 24.
so at that someone who would live that
kind of life and that kind of desperate
addiction
so uh as i said before instead then
going on doing a bunch of drugs and
hoping to get film that way
i feel you have to find those places in
yourself that are that desperate
and that dark and i didn't have the
technique at time to
find it and do it so for that four
months i've
stayed in that type place and it was
pretty heavy it's pretty heavy man
kefir will we see jack bauer again are
you done with 24.
i have learned to never say no when we
finished
when we finished season eight i said we
were done and then we went and made
season nine
look there should be no mistake here i
absolutely love the character and i love
making
24. uh with television the burden is on
the writers
uh and if those writers howard gordon
were to come up with
uh a great idea i would always be open
you'd shave your beard for it oh my gosh
yes he shaves balls for us
kelly s would love to hear you say damn
it chloe one last time
damn it chloe he did it yeah
he [ __ ] did it all right now look
this comes the end of the whole
interview but there's one question
there's an elephant in a room i gotta
ask has anyone ever asked
i'm sure when you were going to get
married to julia roberts i know this is
old [ __ ] hat
this is 30 years old 30 plus 30 years
old so who gives a [ __ ] at this point
right it's been that long i mean you
were kids
then supposedly you had a thing with
julia roberts
you took off to somewhere where'd you go
well i mean that was all
that was all the the the press i mean
the fact was from my sister
ireland yeah i went to ireland ireland
uh
yeah i was gonna say have you guys ever
talked about it was it always
yeah you have yeah we talked yeah sure
yeah well because
go ahead go ahead james no we talked
about we hadn't seen each other
um we hadn't seen each other for over 20
years
and then we contacted i don't know if it
was that long but yeah
sure it was man yeah yeah we probably i
think we hooked up again in
2009 or 2010
and i hadn't seen and nine yeah over 20
for that
well so a long time but yes we had
talked about it
look the thing is is that she's not here
so
right in this room so i'd feel strange
talking about what she told me or
what she told kiefer because she could
speak for herself right but
the large stuff about the press and
being invited to the wedding and then
taking off at the bride and all that
that's all [ __ ] that's all [ __ ]
you know i mean i don't keep for a
specific
relationship and what they were at the
time that's theirs i mean he can speak
but ultimately there was a thing in
uh rolling stone and kiefer said
something
and then you called kiefer right well i
was making a joke about
the country song and someone had asked
me a question about jason i said well i
mean you know
i lost my pickup and my dog and my best
friend and i
miss my best friend you know and so
look the press can make whatever it does
and and
that was a difficult time for me and i
think it was an uncomfortable time for
both of them
um but look honestly the truth
where i'm coming from
you fall in love you fall in love
there's nothing you can do about that
and
and she's an extraordinary person and he
is too and
and you know
timing is what it is and you know
everybody moves on from that
well the maturity though because i mean
most people could never you know get
over something like that or they would
hold grudges or whatever but you guys
had a bond i guess
i don't know i mean george harrison and
eric were best friends till the
bitter end you know but it wasn't it you
know
it it wasn't to and it wasn't that by
the way right so that's right
i figure if they could deal with what
they dealt with we could i think
when we when i saw him again whenever
that was 12 years ago whatever it
sort of it was a few words of this and
that it was more of a laugh and a toast
and i've said in the press before
they've both been subsequently married
since
a couple times i think they're both very
happy in their lives
and what lasted after all that is me and
kiefer is
you know 35-year buddies never got the
truck back
[Applause]
so keith when are you guys playing again
with all this pandemic stuff we've got a
tour in europe in october
and hopefully we'll be able to play here
in the states come july
and where can they go to get some
information your instagram as soon as we
have it
uh we'll put it up on instagram and then
it'll also go through ticketmaster
and your instagram's at kefir southern
one i hope so i think that's what it is
cool all right that sounds good we're
going to go but you're going to play
anywhere in the states before you go
like a little show here too
hopefully uh in in july and then
you know as stuff as stuff is opening up
and i
and i think it needs to go slowly and i
think people need to be smart about this
um but there's a couple
opportunities that might come around in
june where i'll just go out
and do kind of solo shows with the
guitar and
and stuff like that so i'm excited about
that
it's definitely worth it you guys yeah
so if you ever need like
the opener and then then there's a
second band and the third band then you
you need the one first guy to go second
guy
gus and i your son jason we can go you
know get on stage well gus is a much
better guitar player
than anybody gus is awesome the kid's
unbelievable yeah he's
special he's special yeah gus we love
you man you're in your incredible buddy
that he is he loves kiefer this has been
by the way congratulations on quitting
smoking how long have you quit
oh seven months dude that's
how hard is it is it still hard i miss
it
you know uh i'm glad i'm not smoking
how much were you smoking a pack a day
oh stop
a pack a day before noon i've been
trying to get him to stop smoking
since 86 without question i really liked
it
you know i really did uh i did it for a
reason you know
and uh i'm really proud honestly
i don't feel much better for it [ __ ]
but everybody around me
uh feels better feels a lot better
before about this
so well you probably smell better your
clothes smell better
you don't really care about it smells
really good today yeah really was it
is that your car what is that car it's
one of those little fresheners
yeah i thought it was draco i thought
you said his car and it was
like your car the air freshener they
smell good
but to all those folks out there that
have quit smoking into people that are
considering quitting smoking i mean
uh it's hard and i never thought
i would quit uh i was i was i had taken
the long-term plan
uh but it is possible do you feel better
right now than you did when you're
smoking i felt pretty good when i was
smoking
um you know and i ran and i did a lot of
stuff but yes i feel better you said
your voice is better
yeah there's a lot of there's there are
there are significant benefits
including life including including life
yeah
no and and the truth is you know it's
it's made such a difference uh to people
who are around me and
and for that i feel really bad that for
for 40 years that plus yeah
so plus but honestly if you're out there
and you're considering smoking
and it just seems like an impossible
barrier it's not
i mean if you did it if i keep saying
by the way i read an article that jackie
gleason your grandfather smoked six
packs of cigarettes a day
at least four without question just
light light the last one
uh with the new with the net yeah the
last one with the next
well guys i hope i didn't keep you too
long this has been really awesome
brother this has been yeah this has been
really fun thanks for
coming in and you're the first guest
i've had in over a year because i've had
to do zooms
so hell yes and and thanks thanks again
for coming over i really appreciate you
taking your time thank jay
we'll do you next time so we can talk we
have so much more to talk about all
right inside of you
inside of you thank you for allowing me
inside of you keeper today
i really enjoyed the conversation
between these two and when i brought up
uh
julia roberts at the end i saw keith for
kind of giving me that look a little bit
but he was so sweet about it and jason
and uh
you know he gave that little wink when
i'm like well so who went to ireland uh
where did you go with julie and
kiefer goes ireland they went to ireland
uh but you can tell these guys have been
friends for a long time and
you know it's great that they could
still be friends after all these years
and some of the you know [ __ ] and
you know hollywood always
amps everything up like i'm sure there
was a there's a lot of reasons behind
why you know
the wedding didn't happen and you know
and then how
uh jason got involved with julia and it
just gets blown out of proportion and
you got to choose who you're going to
believe and
the fact that their friends and their
friendship is stood this
stood the uh test of time is it shows a
lot it tells a lot about these guys
they're mature and um
so i really enjoyed having them on and
it was weird because i haven't had
someone in the studio for over a year
so i was a little nervous and i was just
sitting across and these guys going okay
we're talking we're talking and uh it
went well it went well
so it was so weird once again if you
want any sunspin merch
uh go to sunspin.com you could book the
band you could book us you could also
book a zoom
uh and zoom us zuma zoom zoom great
merch
you also get any inside of you uh merch
and lex luthor stuff smallville stuff
on the inside of you online store use
the code ryan's discount
15 ryan's discount never what i think
you're going to say
15. ryan's discount 15.
shout out to all my patrons all the
patrons love and thanks everybody for
listening to the podcast every week and
staying with it i mean there's so many
choices and you choose to stay with this
so
i hope you continue to stay and support
the podcast and you know i try to get
the best guests on that i can
and more importantly have just good
conversations with people
and to the point where i hope you learn
something
at the end of each episode that's i
learn a lot
from listening to people and with my add
it's good to put these cans on and just
be able to focus for an hour and
hopefully uh you're enjoying it too i
learned that i'm taller than jack bauer
that was exciting
oh yeah you are taller but you're a tall
guy all right here's a shout out to all
the lovely patrons who make this show
possible and thank you
uh to bryce and thank you for ryan
all right i think thank you i thank you
for ryan here we go
nancy d mary b leah s trisha f
sarah v little lisa you kiku
jill e brian h lauren g nico p robin
asks jerry w robert b
jason w apothean kristen k amelia o
allison l
jess j lucas m raj c joshua d
emily s cjp samantha m jennifer and
jackie p
stacy l carly h carly s jen
s jamal f janelle b carrie b tabatha 272
not to be confused with
the 273. ashley ryan kimberly e mike e
marissa narirello el don sopremo ramirez
beth b
santiego m sarah f chad w leanne p
ray a maya p maisha maddie kendrick f
ashley e shannon d matt w belinda and
kevin v
james r chris h osborne
h h osborne i'm trying to send you
something give us your right address it
got sent back to me
i need your right address osborne was it
just the fjords
i i don't know what the hell happened
but i sent him a box and just got sent
back
where was i got six damn it dave h
samantha s spider-man
chase sheila g ray h tabitha
t misha n h whatever
tom and suzanne
b yes you're guessing and you're right
katie f liliana a michelle k hannah hi
michelle hi hannah b
uh michael s uh talia m luke h
andrew t betsy d and the less is the
last list claire m liz j
laura l chad l rochelle e or rachel e
whichever you want it's rochelle nathan
e brandel
uh taylor k neal a marion e meg k
janel p trav l dan and jennifer j
wayne m diane r ojeda lorraine g
olga c corey m carrie h veronica k big
stevie w
kendall t lindsay m carol d kdg sandy b
angel am eric p rhiannon c stephen m
corey
k super sam and sherry s
thank you guys all for being here for
being a patron
for supporting the podcast in so many
extra ways i love you
um and i got to be doing probably in the
next month i have to be doing a little
uh
zoom with all you guys i could zoom a
zoom zoom in the boom boom
thank you from uh ryan here and myself
michael in the hollywood hills hello
california
hollywood california wave at the camera
ryan
we uh we love you thank you for allowing
me to be inside each and every one of
you
and uh you mean a lot to me so be good
to yourself and i'll see you next week
all right
[Music]